eh bien bon soirée loi bonsoir stephen
bonsoir à tous cinquième partie 3e nul
d'affilée mais c'est sûrement pas la
plus belle nul qu'on ait pu voir en tout
cas pas la plus combative puisque gary
kasparov n'a pas forcé et il a dévié de
mon premier coup on le 4 pour jouer une
anglaise à londres ici et ça n'a pas
marché et stephen voit la première
surprise effectivement kasparov refuse
du coup le combat contre la berlinoise
et il a donc déviée pour une anglaise en
fait donc à ce s qu'il a prévu de
réattaquer la berline aux deux kramnik
plus tard pour ce mieux se préparer
faut dire aussi que les joueurs y hier
avait joué une partie de 6h30 et donc on
peut penser aussi que ils étaient tous
les deux très fatigués voulait peut-être
faire une nulle facile aujourd'hui
les joueurs étaient fatigués c'est clair
effectivement chronique ironique et
sports sous pression sans rappel cette
partie complètement incroyable g
nitrates ligue 1 c'était éprouvant pour
les nerfs
et maintenant le lendemain puisque ici
en jeu deux parties d'affilée et bien
c'était très difficile garry kasparov
n'a pas forcé l'admirable nick non plus
et donc ça s'est soldé par la première
nul rapide de ce match avec peut-être
une erreur de garry kasparov
il joue m qufu prend qu'à valider cinq
qui a l'air au moins de donner la
légalité à chronique voire même petit
avantage et on va voir tout de suite
dans les images sélectionnées
garry kasparov ici en train de réfléchir
et il est en train de s'en rendre compte
après le coup simple de chroniques dont
qui a répandu partout rend fou il est en
train de thornhill halal ne comprend pas
il se dit j'ai oublié quelque chose
c'est sûr
et effectivement on va voir qu'il est
très expressif garry kasparov mais ça on
le savait déjà
voila voila vous lalalalalala incroyable
que s'est il passé il ne comprend pas
nous ne comprenions pas non plus dans le
public ce qui s'était passé
et effectivement garry kasparov s'est
rendu compte à ce moment là que son coup
franc des cinq anneaux donné absolument
pas davantage effectivement il était il
a sûrement vu donc une variante qui
devait être fausse
avant de jouer ce coup il s'est rendu
compte après le coup de chroniques qu'il
avait dû se fourvoyer tout à fait en
fait pendant les commentaires pendant le
direct nous pensons simplement que
c'était une gaffe énorme puisque ça
aurait donné l'avantagé à chronique en
fait apparemment pas du tout puisque
quelques coups après des choix ont
conclu par une partie nulle
très très vite ce qui tend à démontrer
que kasparov bluff avec ses grimaces
auj kasparov effectivement il ne faut
pas s'y fier quand kasparov et des
grands signes s'exclame dans tous les
sens ce n'est pas parce qu'il est mal ça
ne veut absolument rien dire de toute
façon kasparov arborera les mêmes
mimiques
c'est ce que nous avons conclus aux
commentaires exactement alors on va voir
maintenant tout de suite cette partie en
images avec donc l'échiquier de
démonstration et on va voir tout de
suite donc une kasparov choisi le coup 1
ces quatre coups à moitié surprenant
puisqu'on pouvait s'attendre que
kasparov et c'est encore de passer la
défense berlinoise de kramnik mais
peut-être il n'a pas tout abandonné son
idée d'essayer de le démonter chronique
sur ces deux variantes mais il prend un
peu de temps aussi pour que ces second
dans ses ordinateurs aussi essaie de
vérifier si ces idées contre cette
défense peuvent lui donner un avantage
de toute évidence en tout cas kasparov
n'a pas encore trouvé sa partie d'hier
était très longue il n'a pas eu le temps
de bien se remettre au point il n'a
préféré pas renouveler l'expérience de 1
e 4 avait pour affronter la berlinoise
de chroniques
il joue ici c4 qui est sans doute son
ouverture b l'ouverture qu'il veut jouer
en 2d niveau cessons de son deuxième
choix garry kasparov
rappelons quand même qu'à séville en
1987 il avait posé d'énormes problèmes
anatoli karpov franchement ce coup donc
effectivement on le rappellera jamais
assez des joueurs du calibre de kasparov
ça peut jouer aux cartes ça peut jouer
ces quatre ça n'a aucun problème dans
les ouvertures exactement l on va voir
que crâne lisse non plus n'a pas eu de
problème puisqu'il a répété la symétrie
avec ses singles ces cinq cavaliers
trois cavaliers m6 pour l'instant tout
est normal c symétrique
apparemment on s'avance vers une unité
possible dès les premiers coups mais les
blancs ou encore quelques options g3 g3
veut monter le fou sur la case g2 est
normalement ici les noirs réplique très
souvent par le coup g7 g6 tout
simplement avec une position légèrement
meilleur pour les blancs puisqu'ils ont
toujours un temps d'avancé mais à peu
près équilibrés lui à crâne il choisit
tout de suite le combat centrale avec
des cinq et il ne veut pas se laisser
enfermer par kasparov tout de suite il
propose une lutte pour le centre des
cinq effectivement c'est un coup
responsable un coup délicat mais kaspar
hommes ont pesé bien entendu connu c'est
un combat pour le centre surprend des
cinq caves et prend des 5
et là où j'ai deux rouges et deux ça y
est kasparov finissent en développement
et après qu'avait laissé 6-2 kramnik
coût normal aussi on se développe ses
pièces voilà qui va laisser 3 tout ça
c'est logique on attend de savoir ce que
les noirs vont faire avec le fouet
frites
normalement le coup dans cette position
c'est aux 7 5
c'est connu c'est pour empêcher des
quatre normalement on blinde
on met les options aux cinq essais 5
c'est une sorte d'étau de ma roxy qui se
profilent les noirs peuvent avoir cette
configuration électronique n'a pas voulu
utiliser ses moyens il a joué j'ai 6 g
cela se pose et qui propose à des sports
de jouer le coup des deux décades qui
peut se jouer semble-t-il tout à fait
ici on voit que les ramenait les deux
des quatre qui doit être étendue l'air
très très tendu très compliqué ça
deviendrait une sorte de grünfeld avec
g3 en revanche bon évidemment ici on est
dans une sorte d' estaing vienne opposée
avec g3 alors c'est compliqué une
estonienne symétrique
opposée ce qui veut dire en fait que ça
pourrait être
les blancs qui aurait la position des
noirs mais ici ils ont un temps de plus
et donc c'est une variante un peu
spécial un peu particulière qu'on ne
retrouve que dans cet ordre de couleurs
petit roc des rocs et après j'essaie de
trouver cette logique voilà est la
première surprise de kasparov il choisit
un coup alors normalement ici on peut
envisager je crois le coût des deux des
trois qui est un sacrifice de pions qui
est assez intéressant en tout cas avec
les couleurs opposées ça existe mais
kasparov joue un coup surprenant il sort
sa dame très vite et normalement
évidemment tous les débutants on leur
explique qu'il ne faut pas sortir saddam
dans l'ouverture stéphane qu'est ce qui
est passé par la tête de 4,9 à ce moment
là et oui effectivement puisque la dame
qui sort trop tôt peut-être peut être
attaqué par les pièces mineurs qui en
profitent pour se développer attaqué la
dame et gagner du temps bon évidemment
kasparov connaît cette ouverture et qu'
il a calculé que les noirs n'ont pas de
réels moyens de développer des pièces en
attaquant cette dame mais ils peuvent
remplacer leurs cavaliers c'est ce que
va faire kramnik puisse y avait des v6
il attaque la dame attaque la dame là on
ne savait pas trop ce que kasparov
voulait faire de cette dame et il avance
encore en bessin qui alors une case
vraiment surprenante là nous étions
interloqué dans les commentaires comment
garry kasparov hostile
mais saddam aussi loin dans le camp
ennemi alors que celle ci peut être
chassé simplement par les coupes à 6 par
les coûts éventuels m'en fous 17
bref la dame n'est pas sur une casse
table il y a beaucoup de couples et noir
pour attaquer cette dame en revanche en
contrepartie bien entendu ils attaquent
directement l'option c'est exactement le
pion c'est ça qui est attaquée donc ces
assises de la marche pas puisque il
yad'un prend pions c5 et la chronique
trouve une défense originale qu'a leur
originalité qui doit être connue
évidemment mais un petit peu original
puisque le coup calais 17
ça fait donc le quatrième groupe de
cavaliers
voilà il a obligé en fait kasparov il a
obligé kramnik à bouger son cavalier
trois fois quatre fois stéphane quatre
fois même qu'à sport joue détroit et
alors là c'est surprenant ce coût des
trois on ne l'attendait pas enfin moi je
ne l'attendais pas je pensais que
kasparov cherchera des moyens plus
rapide plus immédiat pour exploiter
justement la tacc de stu ans et ses cinq
un coup comme détroit
c'est quand même très lent et ça ne
lutte pas pour le centre puisque pour
l'instant ce les noirs qui sont les plus
avancés si les noirs qui ont plus d
espace à priori dans cette édition on
pensait que le trafic allait s'en sortir
plutôt bien il joue petit rock tout à
fait logique et après fou et trois
autres gars taxes et synchronique trouve
le coup probablement qui posent le plus
de problèmes à kasparov
on va le voir tout de suite c'est à dire
que faudra on a un problème le problème
c'est qu'il faut il faut pas me défendre
le pion c'est pas évident effectivement
c'est pas tout à fait évident et crame
nick trouve cavaliers des cats le coup
spécial la spécialité en fait d'oeil au
cif dordogne voilà c'est un coût qui
attaquent la dame et propose un échange
au centre qui va permettre de ramener le
pion noir sur la case des quatre avec
beaucoup d espace pour les noirs en
contrepartie alors d'autant plus s'il ya
qu'il y ait un problème ici c'est que
les blancs ne peuvent pas jouer deux
cavaliers prend cavaliers c'est
important puisqu'il y avions prend qui
fait une double attaque
et oui qui attaquent à la fois le
cavalier le fou et ça s'appelle une
petite fourchette de pions une petite
fourchette totalement désagréable ce qui
oblige donc kasparov dans cette position
là après qu'elle ait des quatre à
prendre en d4 avec son fou donc à donner
la perdre encore une fois je serais
tenté de dire c'est pas la première fois
depuis le début du match que cramique
joue des ouvertures qui pousse kasparov
a donné sa paire de fou et
on dit on sait aussi que la leaf ou sont
pros kasparov la pièce mineurs qui
préfère effectivement mais c'est la
pièce mineurs que beaucoup de gens
préfèrent beaucoup de joueurs en tout
cas puisque un fou est plus fort qu'un
cavalier tout simplement
mais ici alors ce qui est surprenant
c'est qu'effectivement sur les deux
berlinoise kasparov donne la paire de
fou dès le début et ensuite ils
échangent les dames
alors là qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qu'on redonne un fou puis on prend
attaque le cavaly lecavalier bouge et
krainik immédiatement propose l'échangé
dame
on dirait qu'ils nous font une
thématique je te prends ton fou je
t'échange tadam voilà exactement là
exactement le plan de travnik avec et
noir c'est ça dans ce match je te
prendre vous cherchez un chat dame est à
toi de jouer
voilà vas-y mois mais fou je les garde
pour la finale et vas-y essaie de passer
pour l'instant ça passe pas donc bien
entendu effectivement quand on la perd
deux fois en finale
c'est un avantage donc kasparov qui
allaient blanc a lui aussi des arguments
est ici ses arguments c'est sa 13e
journée la part des parents on va voir
le coup suivant le cosy
à quatre ils n'échangent pas les dames
il garde la pression coûts qui avait été
prédit par toi même d'ailleurs aux
commentaires même pendant direct
envisagée puisque si les noirs prennent
en v5 tout de suite la torah on se
réveille et fait pression sur le pion à
cette simulation de variantes qui n'a
pas été jouer bien sûr
puis on prend b5 et immédiatement on
voit une grosse pression avec la tour 1
notamment sur le pion à 7 et le fou g2
qui peut se réveiller d'un instant à
l'autre avec le tube et celles qui
seront prises ça ça pose des problèmes
vladimir kramnik ne voulais pas de ça et
on le comprend bien
après à 4 il pousse kasparov allait lui
même échangé les dames dans la
radiologie a7 a6 a7 a6 coup très logique
parce que effectivement il ya un
problème pour les noirs dans cette
position les blancs menace d'envahir la
septième rangée en deux coups devenir
ans et 7 par ce coup à six qui force
d'un programme prendre un cavalier prend
qu'un écran et à l'accueil on crame nick
va pouvoir mettre son cabinet sis sur la
caisse des 5 10 il contrôlera lagacé
c'est effectivement très bien joué de la
part de chroniques la kasparov attaque
le cavalier pourquoi aussi pour fixer
les pions noirs puisque les pieds noirs
sur a6 cbc est maintenant sans
complètement vie c est donc sont sous le
feu de l'aduf ou g2 notamment qui tôt ou
tard va probablement pouvoir faire une
pression sur ce tube 17 qui fait déjà
une pression d'ailleurs puisque vrai
cirque du helmand les cavaliers peuvent
disparaître
tout cas peuvent se déplacer donc il ya
des problèmes de fixer les pions baies
sata 6 pointer ici en rouge c'est très
logique cavaliers des 5
et maintenant kasparov doit trouver
quelque chose il faut évacuer ces deux
cavaliers ils sont en trop il commence
donc par le très logique coup cavaliers
en c5 qui augmente la pression sur le
pion de behcet tout de suite puisque ça
attaque ce pion et opal sagement ça fixe
le fossé vitse avancer vite
voilà ça fausse a fixé le fossé mi temps
s'est vite et ça va libérer le fou j'ai
2 après que le cavaliere 3 aura bougé
de plus il ya une menace directe
stéphane on menace de jouer tour 1 sur
la case à 4 d'ici elle attaquera le pire
des quatre honda sera donc cavalier
prend et en cas de défense hausse est de
on pourra quand même à les prendre en d4
puisque le cahier des 500 prises par le
fou g2 qui se réveillera effectivement
une menace directe donc prévenus par
vladimir kramnik tour des huit on voit
que c'est un coup très bon qui défend à
la fois le cavalier et éventuellement le
pion tout à fait chronique
j'aime bien son cavalli centrale
important puisqu'il empêche les
intrusions de tours sur la 7ème
cavaliers d2 kasparov a trouvé un plan
évidemment ça ne nous surprend qu'à
moitié il veut jouer qui s écartent
éventuellement venir sur la case b6 pour
échanger le monstre en d5 c'est très
logique et la cram nick nous rejoue sa
spécialité c'est à dire un coup un bon
coup de miku 1/2 course de dimanche
comme on a pu le voir dans la berlinoise
un petit coup qui l'air de rien mais qui
est mal un tour des huit l'avantagent de
ce cookie curieux c'est que on enlève la
tour de la prise du fond blanc et en
même temps on surprotège le pion
bessette qui est pour l'instant la demie
faiblesse des normes manière tout à fait
donc un petit coup mais malin un petit
malin j'aurais peur chronique direct
kasparov continue avec les c4 et
maintenant chrome nick blinde et joue le
coup eux cet os 6 l'idée est évidemment
c'est d'aller chasser ce calice et 5
avec la manoeuvre rouge et 7 ans les
fuites qui attaquera le cavalier
exactement granik a tout vu et la casse
par on joue le coup tours fc un logique
puisqu'en maintenant à cette colonne
peut s'avérer faible
si les blancs peuvent échanger
lecavalier des 5 et mettre leur tour sur
la cassette et la chronique à vue
un petit coucou grasse carcasse pas
enfin vu aussi mais qui est amusant
fulci soit inattendu inattendue puisque
ce fou on attendait plutôt sur la case
des fuites mais il fait d'abord une
petite diversion il attaque ici la tour
c 1 et on voit que cette tour par ne
peut pas rester sur la colonne sait
puisque si les blancs jouent tour ces
deux simulations petit piège les noirs
jouent dans ce cas là cavalier en b4 et
la tour est complètement dans la boîte
elle est enfermée le fou contrôlant les
deux cases ici le pion contrôlant les
casses c3 bref le cavalier va prendre à
tous
tranquille tranquille donc un piège dans
lequel kasparov n'est pas tombé ce n'est
pas une surprise
christophe a immédiatement kasparov a vu
ça et joue le couteau en b un tour en b1
très logique et maintenant maintenant
cramique joueurs fuite
attaquant le cahier de kasparov qui n'a
pas d'autre choix que de revenir sur la
case d3 le coup b2b 4 n'est pas un coup
il perdrait il très rapidement après
cavaliers prendre b4 et le cavalier
c'est s'inquiète emprise donc ici ça
pose un problème puisque si la tour
vient reprendre et bien c'est tout de
suite la punition foot français 5 avec
comme points de plus avec un peu plus et
donc ce n'est pas bon pour les blancs ce
n'est pas acceptable sur fou et fluide
garry kasparov doit repartir il joue
cavalier b3 et là on voit pas comment
protéger le pion de d4 puisqu'ils ont
des quatre est attaqué on la voit il n'y
a qu'une solution il faut bouger de
fuite angers7
voilà c'est ce que a trouvé cramé qui
pourrait aussi envisager le coup cavalli
b 4 mai qui avait pas l'air aussi bon
c'était pas positionné la foulée 7 le
problème c'est que kasparov peut
remettre son cavalier sur la case c5 et
les du groupe proposait tout de suite
une répétition de coûts donc ça y est
kasparov va peut être menacée entre
guillemets de faire nul mais pour
kramnik c'est bien aussi
disons qu objectivement cette position a
tout d'une position égal puisque on voit
que les pièces blanches qui était très
menaçante au début ne le sont le sont
beaucoup moins maintenant chronique à
conserver ses avantages c'est à dire la
paire de fou pour l'instant le seul
point de kramix et le développement de
ce fou s'est vite s'ils arrivent à jouer
au 6 e 5 et fois aussi ce scellé noir
qui serait mieux
kasparov et donc en orge en danger ici
il faut qu'il joue bien qu'il joue
précis donc il aurait pu jouer qui a
laissé cinq mais il joue le fameux coup
qui lui a provoqué bien des mimiques
ouais si l'on prend des images connues
tout à l'heure c'est après ce coup faut
prendre des cinq rames nick reprendre
tranquillement de la tour est là
kasparov
c'est plus on a l'impression qu'il avait
qui doivent donner l'impression aux
recettes femme paie puisque tu es à la
place de gary kasparov tu peux peut-être
nous simuler son geste tout à l'heure
son geste très technique effectivement
et ce par of donc prêcher sur
l'échiquier était comme ça fait tout de
suite le geste voilà exactement et même
il est allé très très loin en arrière
prescrit le mariage puisqu'il avait
l'air complètement dépité il n'a pas
compris quelque chose on ne sait pas
quoi en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que la tour ou des saintes peut venir
sur la case b5 castrais forte lequel b3
et emprises l'option b 2 le sera aussi
et le pion à 5 également bref là tout en
bessin qui sera superbe dernier prime de
krainik résoudre le problème de sous
c'est vite hélas les noirs seraient
clairement mieux
heureusement pour kasparov il a vu plus
loin j'ai ri dire il m'a vu quand même
qu'il n'était pas en danger
effectivement ils jouent donc cavalli b
d2 et après eux cinq vladimir kramnik
propose nul c'était une surprise quand
même effectivement la suite de la partie
aurait pu être cavaliers en b 6 la tour
viendrait sur la case des cinq cavaliers
prend fou s'est vite on élimine ce fou
et après de trop penser vite probable en
kabylie c4 et ce cavalier complètement
indélogeable oui protégé par le pion de
detroit mais elles tiennent toute la
baraque et ça va être très dur au noir
d'essayer de passer tout à fait donc
peut-être une légère pression pour les
noirs mais en tout cas insuffisant
vladimir kramnik n'a pas voulu jouer
cette position et on comprend très bien
et voilà donc une partie nulle
tranquille aujourd'hui entre guillemets
quand même trois heures de jeu
à noter que c'était quand même la partie
la plus ennuyeuse du match oui il faut
quand même le dire puisqu'on ne peut pas
non plus dire que tout est génial
cette partie n'était pas superbe
stéphane il faut bien le dire elle était
même assez ennuyeuse assez mortels oui
une partie effectivement tout à fait
mortelle on n'a pas eu droit qu'aux
minières dans une position qui semble
égal aussi un feu d'artifice provoqué
par chronique avec le coucher 4 qui a
fait probablement peut-être hier c'était
peut-être là même la plus belle partie
du match c'est clair en tout cas la plus
intéressante au niveau émotionnel il y
avait beaucoup de rebondissements
beaucoup de retournements de situation
critique qui fait des gaffes kasparov
aussi aujourd'hui on n'a pas eu droit à
ça on a une partie plus technique
quand une finale directe
donc assez forcément et encore une fois
c'est un problème pour kasparov parce
que ça prouve qu'il a toujours pas les
moyens avec les blancs d'oeufs vraiment
embêté kramnik que ce soit sur la
défense bernoise de chroniques ou
maintenant sur cet essai avec la la
partie anglaise kasparov n'arrive
toujours pas à mettre kramnik dans des
rails qui serait dans sa préparation
pour être tout à fait ça c'est un
problème pour pour garry kasparov et
l'a2 trouve pas dans les ouvertures il
est mal préparé donc qu'il démarre mal
la deuxième semaine puisqu'on peut dire
que c'est la deuxième semaine puisque le
match a démarré dimanche dernier il
démarre assez mal parce que kramnik
maintenant va avoir plus de fois les
blancs que lui dans la semaine puisqu'il
va avoir deux fois les blancs contre une
fois à kasparov et maintenant encore
kramnik a toujours l'avantagé non
seulement du point
mais en plus du nombre de pièces à jouer
du nombre de fois les blancs a joué dans
la semaine
kasparov et encore une fois sous
pression et ses chroniques qui fait le
jeu pour résumer ce que tu as dit le
deuxième carton commence mal pour
kasparov
on sent qu'il va souffrir donc on vous
donne rendez vous mardi pour un nouveau
direct à partir de 15h heure française
et ça va être chaud parce qu'à cette
fois gravelines calais blanc il sera
plus fatigués par la partie d'hier
puisque demain c'est jour de repos ça va
chauffer ça va chauffer donc avoir
rendez-vous à mardi
je